big the big question I've been getting
pinged by this all day is this RNC
leadership question because a lot of
Republicans
are worried because they think you know
glad they won the house and a couple
more seats look like they're picked up
we're gonna talk to John Duarte in a
minute but in California who do you
think now
should take over as RNC chair we like
Ronald McDonald a lot personally I think
she's she's a great person I like her
heart meet Dylan is a young female
California uh obviously indian-american
look I like Army she's my national
commitment I think she does a tremendous
job but I think Rhonda did a tremendous
job too look would you look across the
country
every Republican entity lost us up the
house I've been leader for four years
we've won every single time what about
early voting for those Senate races she
could have helped on that right I've
watched her down doing it the one thing
I see happening the Senate lost the the
governor's loss the president lost but
the house has won in both Cycles even
we've picked up in California we picked
up in Oregon we picked up in New York
we we won five seats that Biden won by
more than 10 points we beat the D Triple
C chair that hasn't happened in 42 years
I think the quality of the candidate
matters we could have done better in
Pennsylvania with a better governor
candidate there it cost us a thing but
look I saw the resources day I saw the
engagement in there and the RNC is a
small group of individuals the committee
men and committee women I think it
should be decentralized I mean she threw
out that idea on the show last week that
it should be why based in Washington
send it to the to the Heartland to the
importance of States break it out with
everywhere we should decentralize we got
to get out of Washington I looked that
from a government point of view why is
the Department of energy in Washington
what do they produce and why is the
department
get it out to the American public let
them understand what we will we continue
to make progress in California a
California's just got to turn at some
point we won in Congress every single
second we won in La we want we won three
seats that Biden had carried by more
than 10 points so you know what we
proved in the house we can win in every
single place the quality candidate
matters having the resources and having
the right so your message again Tom
Tillis McConnell hold off
29 days can't you wait because what will
happen then is you'll get a Republican
bill out of the house you'll be in a
stronger negotiation position and we'll
be cutting instead of adding more money
it's great to see you thank you so much
thank you coming in tonight I really
appreciate it thank you leader McCarthy
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else